j'accueille andré glucksmann
soir ça va bon ben on verra bien alors
vous publié chez plon
une rage d'enfants dans une rage de dent
non ou publié chez plon
une rage d'enfants dans le pitch poète
est comment une rage d'enfant devient
colère de toute une vie en effet ce
n'est pas une autobiographie classique
mais plutôt un parcours le parcours d'un
enfant qui a grandi dans la
clandestinité dans la france occupée et
qui crient depuis son désaccord avec ce
qu'ils font comme si de rien n'était ou
comme si rien n'avait été alors à
prendre les choses au départ d'abord
votre nom glucksmann en français ça veut
dire homme bonheur mais la vérité c'est
qu'en fait vous raconter très bien que
c'est l' indice de l'humeur du
fonctionnaire austro hongrois qui était
chargé de nommer les juifs
alors quand il était de mauvaise humeur
il appelait le mec shechtman l'homme de
merde quand il était avec quelqu'un
c'est normal il appelait goldman
l'usurier et quand il était de bonne
humeur
bonjour il applique dux man le veinard
donc c'est comme ça que votre ancêtre a
été baptisé glucksmann mairie n'était
peut-être de bonne humeur une
particulièrement facétieux parce que mon
ancêtre on vendait des du chiffon rouge
était pas si veinards que ça en fait si
il était veinards puisqu'il a eu un
monde vénère voilà alors vos parents
donc été tous les deux citoyens
autrichiens il avait quitté l'europe
pour la pour la palestine
évidemment avant la création de l'état
d'israël c'était avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ils se sont rencontrés à jérusalem ils
sont tombés amoureux l'un de l'autre ils
se sont plus visiblement ils ont fait
deux enfants
et alors ce qu'il y a deux
caractéristiques quand même d'un c'est
énorme ce qu'ils sont revenus à l'europe
un moment où tous les juifs fuyez
l'europe
exactement jenson tel courant ils sont
retournés et pas n'importe où ils ont
ils sont allés en allemand c'est 1930 à
peu près à l'époque les ssds à
nettoie les rues avec des barres de fer
et ils sont juifs ils sont à l'époque
communiste et ils ont décidé de résister
à hitler ils ont pensé que c'était là
que se posait le problème est donc ici
sans elles et ils sont montés au front
mais alors complètement à contre-courant
alors ils y vont en plus avec 2 avec
deux fillettes quoi c'est pas à l'épaule
gauche finit avec vos deux soeurs donc
hélas il se met au service de
l'internationale communiste dans
l'allemagne de hitler
jugez en 1937 ou là ils sont ils sont
découverts il fut à paris et vous vous
naissez à boulogne en fait oui mais bien
bien tranquille français oui français
grâce au droit du sol de la grée me
voilà le saint louis alors votre père
meurt en 1940 sur un paquebot torpiller
entre calais et douvres alors dit qu'il
était passager d'un navire bourg et
d'émigrés germanophone est en fait c'est
des gens qui voulaient aller en
angleterre surtout expulsé d'angleterre
enfin bon ils circulaient et puis
finalement ils se il ya des torpilles
qui les ont descendu probablement des
torpilles allemande à moins que ce
soient des bateaux qui se faisait la
guerre enfin bref on sait personne ne
sait non loin des mythes dans ma famille
on disait mon que mon père était
magnifique qu'il était qu'il avait
laissé les vieux prendre les canots de
sauvetage qu'il était resté avec le
capitaine et ses classes possibles on
suis pas sûr parce qu'il avait aussi une
maladie un brin temps et donc il a coulé
à pic alors pendant l'occupation vous
retrouver avec quatre femmes
votre grand mère en fait qu'ils se
laissent mourir parce qu'elle sent
qu'elle est à un poids pour vous allez
vous dites trop juive trop allemand de
trop facilement repérer un ou deux
français et quand même s'étend dans la
france occupée ce n'était pas vraiment
un commandés et donc les trois autres
femmes c'était votre mère et et vos deux
soeurs voilà mais vous êtes tous dans
l'illégalité c'est à dire que votre mère
refuse de porter l'étoile jaune
pas question d toile jaune et didier
venait d'allemagne et deux salles et
elle savait ce qui l'attendait donc à
vous vivez dans la clandestinité entre
l'âge de 3 ans et 7 ans vous avez deux
noms
deux prénoms vous appelez joseph
glucksmann et andré rivière alors
pendant l'occupation
c'est la clandestinité donc que vous
dites pas de foyers seulement des
domiciles l'incertain était la norme
oui mais l'influent j'attendrai pas là
dessus je ne suis pas une grande victime
un grand martyr etc
je suis un boum et je trouve la
situation normale c'est ça que je
voudrais faire remarquer quand même mais
vous vous participer quand même à la
lutte
vous allez fermer une maison vous êtes
chargé quand même d'aller fermer une
maison où on cache des valises darmon
cachent des clandestins à votre niveau
ajouté chargé de fermer la porte à clé
quand il y avait personne dans la maison
ouais et de planquer la clé sous une
pierre un endroit précis ce que une fois
je n'ai pas fais là je me suis vraiment
fait attraper mais la maison était pas
loin de l'immeuble de la milice quand
même ah oui c'était en face c'était
entre le chemin de fer et m'amuse c'est
une des maisons parce que j'ai vécu dans
vingtaine de maisons mais aussi dans des
pensions religieuse et aussi à l'affairé
lacroix furieux c'est drôle vous étiez
enfant de choeur ah mais ça c'était pour
les tartines mais aussi pour jouer la
comédie aussi j'étais très content alors
je croyais jouer la comédie au fond les
bonnes soeurs devait être au courant du
curé devait être au courant et ont
protégé le petit livret qui se croyait
très mal alors quand vous êtes raflé
vous est emmené dans un camp de
regroupement à bourg lastic et là votre
mère commençaient aujourd'hui ce qu'elle
le savait elle avait connu l'allemagne
la véritable destination finale de tous
ces gens les gardiens s'en inquiète et
il profite de votre nationalité puisque
vous êtes français pour vous ranger tous
dans les non juifs
il est très fort sire que votre mère a
tellement gueuler quoi qu'il m'en elle
vous a sauvé la vie elle s'est sauvée
exactement ça c'est la grande leçon
première ne semble mon existence mais je
les sucs après c'est que l'insolence et
la vérité dit paix en fait elle risquait
de panique est absolument tout le camp
parce qu'elle ne savait où on allait les
gendarmes n'ont donc pris à part une ou
dix lits mais pourquoi je l'affirmé je
dis la vérité vous le savez plus où
moins
moi je l' ai vu je sais que d'arabes
existe à une cuisse depuis 1933
donc je sais très bien où des gens vont
je vais pas leur cacher pourquoi genre
cacheraient ils ont besoin semble lui
aussi
alors après la guerre il ya un autre
épisode aussi caire incroyable cette
histoire d'aider rothschild donc vous
retrouver au château de ferrières qui a
été transformé en foyer pour enfants
rescapés et injurié les rothschild qui
viennent voir un peu tout ce petit monde
comment ça s'organise et là vous jetez
vos souliers sur vos bienfaiteurs tout
le monde est assemblé tout le monde
ville retour de la paix finalement il ya
quand même un autre qui sera établi et
puis je déballe là dedans je jure urnes
personne ne comprend je détache monsieur
sûr je la lance sur des officiels on
écrase le court j'avais beaucoup de
gosses complète beaucoup plus fou dingue
que moi parce que c'était des gosses qui
revenait toute l'europe des camps de la
mort et c'est qu'il m'avait raconté moi
je n'avais pas subi ça je ne m'en étais
même pas douter en fait c'était mon
premier livre parce que je crois que ce
que je ne supportais pas c'était le
l'idée que la paix était revenue et
qu'il fallait plus penser à ce qui
s'était passé voilà donc première colère
face aux rothschild cette colère ne vous
quittera plus et ensuite votre mère
retourne à vienne parce que l est pas
bien en france et là c'est incroyable
vous êtes français vous restez seul à
paris à dix ans avec une chaussure
vous choisissez la france à ce moment là
je choisis un pays qui qui est porteur
des idées de révolution qui est porteur
des idées de liberté
à l'époque la france représentait
beaucoup c'était le l'endroit où toutes
les nouvelles idées apparaissait alors
c'est pas du tout parce qu'on était
fermée c'est l inverse les américains
étaient arrivés il était très
décontracté nous avait libérés mais il
avait surtout apporter le jazz art et
apporter le jazz la grande littérature
le cinéma et c'est quoi et la france
l'avait bien pris c'était saint germain
s'était arrêtée socialiste et tout le
monde dans le monde entier discutait de
ce qui se passait entre la france
finalement et là mais rien alors
toujours précoce à l'âge de 13 ans vous
adhérez au pc quand même énorme
c'est fou un usager un peu trafiqué
quand même way et vous y est resté
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans jusqu'à l'entrée
des tanks soviétiques dans dans budapest
en 56 alors vous avez refusé à ce
moment-là lénine staline et vous réfutez
dont vous devenez à l'époque anarcho
maoïste où comment disait mao spontex
principe mao était la solution pour
seulement c'est pas du tout ça on avait
besoin d'une effigie qu'on ne
connaissait pas un pour contrer le parti
communiste français qui lui était pro
soviétique alors comme les chinois
s'engueuler avec les soviétiques
d'accord bon on pouvait rester
révolutionnaire d'accord et discuter
très fermement avec la cgt particulière
alors vous dites c'est quand même le
grand regret de ma vie d'adulte ça oui
c'est une honte parce que parce que la
révolution chinoise a été une des pires
st nom la pire
du 20e siècle enfin via deux millions de
morts c'est entre 50 et 100 millions
vous dites ce fut je l'espère ma
dernière complaisance avec un mangeur
d'hommes d'où le titre de votre bouquin
en 75 la cuisinière et le mangeur
d'hommes qui est un best-seller que j'ai
vu à l'époque que j'ai acheté que j'ai
dévoré à l'époque je dois vous dire
c'était un choc terrible vous le savez
d'ailleurs saviez-vous réglement
jourdain et oui c'est la première fois
donc un écrivain juif de surcroît
comparer le nazisme et le communisme
part ça il ya des gens que ça beaucoup
m'arrêter c'est pas que j'étais le
premier à parler des camps c'était une
chose connue mais je me suis demandé
pourquoi connaissant cette chose sarthe
savait qu'ils avaient au moins 10
millions de morts en russie soviétique
et pourquoi finalement l'acceptait à
gauche et j'ai pensé que c'était à cause
du marxisme à cause des des bons des
bonnes idées des bons sentiments faire
le bonheur du peuple malgré du million
de man etc etc
voilà ça a été les nouveaux philosophes
oui chez plon
m
alors quelques questions d'actu andré
glucksmann vous étiez pour
l'intervention américaine en irak
vous êtes contre l'intervention russe en
tchétchénie et pourquoi parce que je
pense que saddam hussein c'est bien pire
que tout ce que les américains ont
commis comme crémer comme horreur depuis
savoir bougrad guantanamo et ses
terrains que saddam hussein c'était deux
millions de morts en 20 ans de dictature
que jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'intervention américaine avec toutes
ces erreurs 1
c'est ça non préparation de la suite bon
pourquoi poutine poutine c'est l'homme à
la tête de l'armée russe qui a rasé la
première capitale européenne qui a été
rasé depuis varsovie en 1944 ces grosses
ni quatre cent mille habitants
alors bien sûr c'est officiellement de
la lutte contre un terrorisme mais y
imaginer que le gouvernement anglais
race belfast
oui sous prétexte de lutter contre les
terroristes bagnols en bas au oui
ouvrage que l'espagnol rasd bilbao
bon alors que moi je vais pas compris
qu'on puisse rester silencieux devant ça
entre temps la russie a supprimé les
libertés qu avait plus ou moins cor
dessine supprimer les libertés des mass
média devenu extrêmement nationaliste au
mauvais sens du terme
la preuve que la tchétchénie s'intéresse
aussi l'ensemble de la russie et
l'ensemble europe quoi alors vous êtes
pour la publication de caricatures de
mahomet mais contre les quolibets sur
les chambres à gaz pourquoi ben alors
parce qu'il ya la différence entre une
opinion et un fait les chambres à gaz
c'est un fait c'est tout c'est un fait
alors que l'idée qu'on peut se faire de
dieu et des prophètes
elle est à la liberté de chacun je suis
pour la libre expression
je suis aussi pour le respect des
vérités c'est pour ça que les islamistes
en fait tu parle de religion de la shoah
c'est pour mettre les deux choses au
même niveau
voilà ouais mais excusez moi c'est pas
une question de religion de savoir
ça a existé
alors votre livre andré glucksmann
s'appelle une rage d'enfants en interne
une interview rage est ce que j'avais la
rage de vivre non et pourquoi non
pourquoi parce que j'ai la rage de
survivre mais pas la rage de vie est-ce
que vous avez la rage de ne pas réussir
à vous coiffer correctement bon bah ça
s'est passé il ya plus grave je n'y
arrive pas je n'y arrive pas depuis 30
ans 40 ans 50 ans tant pis comment un
bon c'est bien pourquoi ça va est-ce que
vous avez la rage de voir chirac
président au début pas du tout ouais
vous début pas du tout il a fait un très
beau discours au sujet de la france la
français de vichy il a installé des
canons dessus de sarajevo pour réalité
des massacres
bon j'étais plutôt pour aujourd'hui je
trouve très très très usés et puis pas
mal
usant est-ce que vous avez la rage de ne
pas avoir changé le monde je l'échangé
mais voilà
excusez moi mais par nous tous les
révolutionnaires qui peuplent absolument
toute la france depuis 50 ans j'ai
soutenu des révolutions qui ont réussi
est-ce que vous avez la rage quand
bernard lévy vend plus de livres que
vous mais à écouter
au début c'était pas le cas ensuite ça
l'a été
maintenant je m'en fous lui je suppose
il s'en fout aussi on est à ses copains
est-ce que vous avez la rage orient les
filles de 20 ans avec leurs petits seins
de bakélite de bakélite à elle peut pas
tous les ans vous fout la rage un nom
enfin des petits seins j'adore les
grossistes
oui oui et non ça me fait extrêmement
mal à l'aise
ça dure depuis très longtemps et je
trouve que les français sont aussi mal à
l'aise mais avec mauvaise conscience
c'est à dire qu'il ne donne pas une
pièce de mener moi j'ai vécu dans un
village dont 80 le tout le village a
voté à gauche
et puis il ya un gars qui est mort dans
une grange avec mort de froid et tout le
village s'est retournée en dix ans mais
c'est la faute au gouvernement alors que
n'importe qui aurait pu les bergers donc
oui ça me donne ça donne froid dans le
dos les fds qu'ils avaient la rage en
voyant la place de la france dans le
monde
oui oui oui je trouve que c'est
lamentable
la france aujourd'hui elle se bat sur
quoi elle se base sur l' attaque et sur
les 5,5 pour cent pour la restauration
ouais bon écoutez excusez moi mais dans
le monde tel qu'il est il ya des il ya
des causes plus grande et la france
normalement il aurait dû se féliciter ne
serait-ce que se féliciter de la
libération de l'ukraine de la
alors j elle devrait s'inquiéter des
guerres absolument affreuse pas
seulement en tchétchénie mais aussi au
darfour ouais
et là elle est la grande absente est-ce
que vous avez la rage de voir que milo
selick ne sera pas jugée non paix à son
âme
je pense simplement que c'est une
critique affaire au tribunal ça a duré
trop longtemps
est-ce que vous avez la rage de voir
mourir un jour ah non pas du tout ça me
rassure plutôt ouais bah oui ça me
rassure sur mon état de décrépitude ça
s'arrêtera est-ce que vous avez la rage
quand vous prenez un râteau et qu'une
femme opus
non non ça me paraît à peu près normale
enfin je suis plutôt étonnés de l'
inverse
est-ce que vous avez la rage quand on
vous prend pour un vieux fou toujours en
colère non mais ça m'embête
messieurs
de toi garde
car pas de chance pour un mec qui
s'appelle le veinard vous devez faire la
promotion du livre fine 10 concurrents
du vôtre et qui sort en même temps bon
alors vous avez american vertigo et
c'est un je suis pas d'accord avec tout
ce qu'il ya dedans mais son anti anti
américanisme me semble juste et son
analyse des prisons en amérique me
semble absolument vrai on dit que abou
ghraib et guantanamo
c'est à cause de la guerre mais non
c'est essentiellement à cause du système
pénitentiaire américain donc american
vertigo fair play
je te hais